I made the mentor me series because I
wanted to spend a little bit more time
around super successful entrepreneurs
and hopefully have some of their magic
dust rub off on us and change the way we
think change our habits and change the
way that we see the world so today we're
going to learn from Gary Vaynerchuk on
hustle mentor meet Gary
what I would say hustle is to me is that
when you have passion around something
that you are squeezing every last bit of
the juice out of the orange right to me
Hustle is maximizing the energy you're
putting into somebody I'm blown away by
people saying that they're hustling and
they want to achieve these great things
and then their actions don't match it's
like saying you really want to lose
weight while eating a Big Mac right so
to me Hustle would be putting all your
effort into achieving the goal at hand
and for me that means making every
minute count hiring a full-time
assistant who's ever I mean Friday night
didn't happen because I was hustling
like every minute like if I miss my 15
minutes to tape the show I've missed my
15 minutes because there's so much
hustle my day there's no you know
there's no like hey I there's no hanging
out there's no like time we're like if I
get to do like one joke with you guys as
I'm walking in between meetings we like
to find out to be like a rare
acquaintance situation like like
occurrence not acquaintances Hustle is
putting it all in a line Hustle is
waking up one day the day before you
died and realizing you gave it your all
into the parenting of your children the
building of your businesses the four
lamp three that you wanted to do
whatever you define it's just you know
all-in emotionally and executional II in
theory and strategy and an execution
hustle is a word to so many people even
to some of my hardcore fans I'm sorry to
call you out but I follow you like you
follow me and people talk about the
hustle but then you're talking about
your 6 o'clock you know happy hour drink
or your video game or this and that and
here we are in holidays and everybody's
going to their holiday party and I've
got one meeting coming up right now two
meetings after that we're doing all my
email and so while everybody's drinking
some goddamn eggnog I continue the
hustle and so you can say it or you
couldn't do it but I highly recommend
you do both I feel like I've lost my
hustle help what do I do
Adam anybody who's losing their hustle
has a lot of variables and there's a lot
of variables in this episode this is the
variable episodes there's a lot of
context books it's not just direct
answers today um listen you might have
you might not be passionate about your
North Star anymore
I I've been going through something let
me actually break some shattering news
here for the first time in my life I've
been thinking about weird things like
sabbaticals
and building a business school in Haiti
for five years and like like I love
listen I'm still all about buying the
New York Jets and it's the process of
that and the game but it's amazing for
me to be into of myself the maturity
like as you get older like just dip like
my kids are six and three and they're
interesting like it's they're
interesting and like you start you know
I start projecting what do they look
like at 13 and 15 like if you're really
cool to like I don't believe in the
school system as much as everybody like
to I just take them and go do something
rogue like just different things like
you just evolved and and you might have
just lost your North Star the thing that
you thought you were going for might not
be it's why it was always happy that I
didn't want a million bucks or they want
fame or I didn't want a car private
plane or these little things like it was
fun to be like I want to buy the Jets
and what that always meant to me is I
want the process of buying the Jets
which means I get the hustle forever
because that's my that's who I am maybe
you've lost who you are or what you want
or maybe you've accomplished kind of or
maybe you feel it's achievable I would
be crushed if I thought what I wanted to
achieve
was super achievable I mean it happened
to me in the limas is happening at
Vayner like as Vayner is becoming a
player in the agency world and we're not
like uh now we're like uh like and soon
we're gonna be like oh like you know
like like that's not as fun for me I
like being the underdog
I like the climb you know I like that so
maybe that's happened maybe you're just
tired I mean I think one of the things
that the New York Jets do for me that
nobody understands is those hours
actually you just caught something on
dailyvee right me talking Jeff that was
the first time I talk business to a Jets
game in 15 years I looked at my phones a
long time it was a very big thing and
only spend a second on it like I am
escaped and we're lacked and by the way
I didn't care about it like that's how
excited like those three four hours of
escapism maybe need some vacation time I
maybe you need to look at the people
around you maybe you need a change maybe
you need to break up with your boyfriend
or girlfriend like there's like there's
a lot of intense different things that
can be happening or maybe you can take a
step back and really listen to this
statement which is you've lost your
hustle because you really are not in
tune to why you're doing it right you're
just not in tune to what you're doing it
that that that you're maturing and
realizing like a Ferrari or a fat watch
or courtside tickets or custom mics I
would just wanted to show them you know
is not what you're living for and so um
you know it's funny tonight I'm going to
the charity water gala I never thought
of myself ten years ago somebody who'd
be so involved in nonprofits sitting on
the board of pencils of promise donating
I was you know I was old so gone 40 I'm
older like this this new narrative of
much better people and that's what I
think you guys all are I think you're
much better generation I grew up
thinking I'll get rich and when I'm old
I'll be like giving out money and doing
that stuff so you just evolved right and
so maybe maybe you like me like I
haven't gone completely like I don't
have enough money like my kids can give
away all the money but I can't I don't
have that luxury yet but maybe you want
to do nonprofit maybe you want to build
schools for pencils of promise and we'll
take you and Laos like maybe you've lost
your purpose so take a good step back
shut down shut down for 24 48 72 hours
go away go away like this this is how I
want you to shut down go to Airbnb this
is a 2016 way to shut down go to
Airbnb find a very remote place you know
type left to go I'm taping so yeah I'm
just wrapping up the show
sorry go to go to Airbnb find a very
remote place that's you get to at a low
cost like a crappy cabin far away on a
four-hour drive where you can like just
drive because you can or like somebody
will drive you there or like hitchhike I
don't give a crap lowest cost farthest
away seclusion and just be with yourself
and start talking to yourself for real
for like really talk to yourself a real
one of the great things I do with myself
is I talk to myself for real you know
really nobody is a harsher critic and a
bigger fan of themselves than me and I
think that friction in both directions
matters how someone is putting it all on
the line period simple you know like the
way it sounds because it's the truth
because you're just not working also is
waking up one day the day before you die
and realizing you gave it your all into
the parenting of your children the
building of your businesses the four
lamp three that you want to do whatever
you define it's just you know all-in
emotionally and executional II in theory
and strategy and an execution
you know you don't hustle when you get
sick in the same way you don't hustle
when you get sleep you know we've got
that coal car that did really well write
that quote where I'm like it's not what
you do you know it's not how many hours
you're awake it's what you do within
them I'm thrilled to get six or seven
hours of sleep I love when people think
I'm on three or four hour guy I'll take
eight every night because those other 16
I will dominate your face I love people
who sleep for hours but like chill and I
and chilling is like just not doing
something important for 40 minutes or
like having a conversation on the
trading floor for 30 minutes about the
big game or what happened in the Oscars
last night who gives us execute and so
boy who is it for me I'm purely focused
on my thing some people like thirty
minutes of talking about the Oscars
because it breaks up their day that's
their rest you do you but let me say
this when you're sick or when you're
sleeping rest your body's telling you
something and so like weirdly maybe I
was sick once in the last 11 years I was
pumped let me just say that again
because I don't know if everybody
understood that I really wish I was sick
one day this year I would really enjoy
the time off
I'd enjoy relaxing and the kids come you
know me she comes home at 3:00 like it'd
be fun it'd be fun but but there's
something subconsciously that's really
trying to not allow me to do that in a
world where I take 100-plus flights
where that place is like I don't know I
like you know remember how a couple of a
single drug I said the 20 to 30 year old
Gary Vee is soft compared to me that guy
gets sick now I don't and I do think it
has a lot to do with my focus on it so I
do think you can out hustle your
sickness to some degree but when you
succumb to it because at some level we
all do I think you need to just relax
and enjoy it
how do you get money to do what you love
you don't write
I lost a shitload of money when I
started doing what I loved what you do
is you position yourself to succeed so
for example if you're doing something
else at you and you want to do this
thing you love you do it after hours you
work 9:00 to 6:00 you get home you kiss
the dog and you go to town right I mean
you start building your equity in your
brand and whatever you're trying to
accomplish after hours you everybody has
time stop watching lost that's a good
overheard right
that was a good overheard so you know
what I mean I mean if you want this if
you want bling-bling if you want to buy
the Jets if you want to do [ __ ] work
that's how you get it it's all I got
there's just nothing else to say thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what you think
of the video leave it down in the
comments below I will join the
discussion thanks again for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon